اتحدث عن مصر في مصر حيث اشهر لهجه عربيه
سال الناس ما احب لهجه عربيه بالنسبه لك
وما اسهل لهجه عربيه بالنسبه لك ايضا غير
المصريه طبعا نتابعونا ونرجع لكم
[موسيقى]
احب اللهجه المصريه وبس الخليجي الاردن
العراق سوريا كلهم بنفهم عليهم ناس حلوين
حلوين
اللهجه السوريه
[موسيقى]
بحب كل اللي هاجات العربيه بس انا يا رب
العجله يا قلبي اللهجه السعوديه بفضل
اللهجه الشاميه دايما يعني بميل ناحيه
سوريا ولبنان وكده لا الحاجات دي بحبها
جدا اسهل اللهجه بعد اللهجه المصريه عشان
هي الاكثر انتشار طبعا هي لهجه الامارات
عشان فيها مصطلحات عربي كثير وسهله يعني
كم
[موسيقى]
الاردنيه وممكن اللهجه التونسيه برده
شايفاها ان هي سهله وحاجه ثانيه هم دائما
بيقولوا مصر ام الدنيا هم بيحبوا المصريين
قوي
مصريه اسهل منها كمان انا بافضل الكلام
[موسيقى]